كيف يحمي بوتين نفسه من الاغتيالات سؤال
اصبح حديث السوشيال ميديا مع اعلان روسيا
احباطها محاوله لاغتيال زعيمها على غرار
الحقيبه النوويه التي ترافقه في كل مكان
يحظى بوتين بحراسه مشدده اينما فصحيفه
نيويورك بوست كشفت انه يحيط نفسه في نخبه
من حراس يمتلكون قدرات خاصه ويلقبون
بالفرسان الى جانب اشخاص اخرين يقومون
بتذوق طعامه فقط لحمايته من الاغتيالات
المحتمله بسموم قد تدس في اكله الصحيفه
الامريكيه كشفت ايضا ان بوتين يركب سيارته
وسط قافله من عربات مدرعه تحمل جنود
المسلحين برشاشات وصواريخ محموله مضاده
للطائره والمسيرات ولا ننسى القناصين
الذين يعتلون اسطح المنازل المحيطه بتواجد
الرئيس واخيرا ورغم نفع رسمي ما زالت هناك
تقارير تتحدث عن استخدام بوتين لشبيه له
ينوب في الظهور عنه بالمناسبات العامه
[موسيقى]